pourquoi salut à tous et à toutes
vous êtes à tout salut ya quelques temps
sur instagram et sur twitter j'ai
partagé une illusion d'optique que je ne
connaissais pas et apparemment vous non
plus d'ailleurs n'hésitez pas à me
rejoindre sur ces réseaux là alors
aujourd'hui on va se faire une vidéo sur
des illusions d'optique que vous ne
connaissez pas forcément il y en a deux
trois qui sont un petit peu célèbre mais
je pense que vous allez faire des
petites découvertes pas dénuée d'intérêt
pour faire la vidéo j'ai demandé à
farhot si vous voulez venir histoire de
voir quelle réaction lui il aurait face
à toutes ses illusions la plus
intéressant que juste voulu montrer il a
dit oui merci à lui laura faroult dont
vous pouvez retrouver la chaîne de la
description et de la description vous
retrouverez aussi tous les fichiers que
j'ai utilisée dans la vidéo si vous
voulez les télécharger avant de
commencer la vidéo deux informations
rapides avec force qui est l'éditeur du
livre que vous avez ici et que vous avez
peut-être déjà chez vous si non il ya un
lien de la description on organise une
tournée de conférences dans pas mal de
villes en france y en a qui vont se
rajouter vous avez tous sur le site
internet www.info bien l'écart point fr
et toute manière j'en parle souvent sur
twitter un stade et vous pouvez
également je vous rappelle réserver les
places pour mont olympia
l'année prochaine le plus tôt sera le
mieux parce que plus on sait le monde
qui aura plus je peux pouvoir organiser
des choses et maintenant je chausse mes
petites lunettes et c'est parti je vais
vous présenter et présenter à mr farhot
des illusions d'optique qui pour
certaines sont pas connues ouais
d'autres sont un petit peu connu c'est
d'ailleurs si tu t'intéresses à ça je
suppose canard à détroit de cook dont
trois membres de notre passage à l'école
primaire on les a vus dans le magazine
quoi et comme tout le monde on apprécie
ça donc on cherche tous en avoir plus
mais je suis pas à fond dedans donc que
les taux de vente de me faire découvrir
on peut être commencer par celle ci
parce qu'elle est extrêmement connue la
tamise robe veut vraiment emballant
c'est le débat de direct star et des
couches rouge laquelle il est englué art
cette robe
alors moi visera visuellement je la vois
de couleur bleu et marron
oui et d'autre la voix blanche et or
ça me saoule déjà non il n'y a pas de
blanc c'est du bleu je suis désolé et
c'est vrai alors tu sais que sa vraie
couleur d'ailleurs ces bleus et noirs il
y en a peut-être qui la voit blanc et or
quand on sait c'est juste une question
du cerveau si le cerveau se dit de la
robe est éclairé par la lumière du jour
alors ils l'interprètent sa balance des
blancs dans notre petit cerveau en mode
blanc et or
oui s'il comprend que c'est de la
lumière artificielle il refait sa
balance des blancs comme ta caméra et se
disent et benoît notre cerveau il
interprète le contexte dire que là il ya
des gens qui la voient vraiment amusé à
sa fin la manifester vous alors je veux
vous voir des si tu veux la vérité là je
la vois bleu et noir mais quand j'allais
imprimer ce matin je la voyais blanc et
or sur le papier as-tu oneway l'âge de
vos noix pour le prochain je vais te
demander simplement de me dire ce que tu
vois comment ça s'appelle ce que tu vois
et vous aussi vous pouvez dire d'aller
grandir ce que vous voyez et damman donc
ça c'est quoi donc je vois des spirales
d'un escargot qui tombe jusqu'aux
centres jusqu'à l'infini jusqu'à
l'infini on est sûr que ça va jusqu'à
l'infini
non j'ai plus l'impression qu'il ya un
point bleu au centre donc ça va
s'arrêter mais c'est tout petit donc je
ne sais pas jusqu'où ça va donc une
spirale oui c'est parce qu'en fait il ya
pas de spirale tu vas tu va leur mettre
un poteau en bonne came back comme ça je
suis pas tout seul à réfléchir mais du
coup et si tu veux t'en convaincre
tu peux dans l'espoir d'un certain
exemple la deuxième glace improbable par
contre ce qui se passe j'étais obligé de
faire ça moi aussi j'en ai oui mais
d'accord est d'accord mais j'arrive je
le trash mais que le voir en fait c'est
ouf ou pas oui celle ci j'ai mis du
temps mais aussi à amiens au départ avec
l'apparence et les granges le voir mais
grand savoir quels sont les petits si
n'importe quoi pour toi mais juste avec
avec des carrés blancs et noirs on
reprogramme toute la perception mais tu
sais quels moyens je tombais malade là
je rentre pas ce soir à mes lèvres
mourir au cerveau je suis fait piquer
les yeux mon ami clément s'est préparé
de cette vidéo du jour où tu as bien
voulu qu'on fasse un ensemble que j'ai
commencé à préparer et où la fin de la
journée j'avais les yeux comme ça j'ai
vu que tu vas kiffer résultant du retard
piles de papier là qui est en train
d'arriver petit à petit donc que penses
tu de cette demoiselle il y est ce que
tu la reconnaît à alors je suis très
mauvais pour madame tu le reconnais
maintenant je ne vends pas question
alors je suis désolé pour ceux qui
reçoivent aussi bouger en radio que
c'est une bonne culture ans je la trouve
comment bignona mignonne
l'air très très maquillée très très
maquillée pas mort a dit m haies femmes
ça peut faire partie des profils de
filles qui te plaisent je suis pas trop
fan des filles qui se sortent et c'est
ça c'est qu'elle ait les yeux avertis et
la bouche sont mis d'accord j'étais
plaît toujours
maintenant voilà du coup pas des masses
elle beaucoup moins on dirait je préfère
passer une cité de noms mais est-ce que
c'est horrible
alors pour les yeux ça ce cap pour le
match est assez dingue l'escorté avec la
paupière effectivement là c'est assez
simple je pense que que tu connais pas
tous mais oui je me connais réponse et
je me suis fait [ __ ] dans la tête l'a
évidemment j'ai vraiment penché entre
toi tu là il mangera droit sur la gauche
à droite tu vas me dire qu'ils sont tous
perdre elle est complètement droit
exactement de la même manière vous non
franchement c'est tout il n'y a pas dit
le jure l'afp non mais c'est çà et là on
voit c'est à chaque fois avec le blanc
et noirs c'est l'entrelacement dublin en
fait un qui croit que ça mais ça il y en
a des centaines et des centaines ça
c'est un des moins connus ce dessin mais
il faut vérifier en fait avec le pattern
qui a derrière quoi si on regarde de
loin comme ça les oies tu vois bien
qu'il ya un
il a au moins deux jours qui sont un peu
penchée sur le côté pervers pascal à
chaque fois sur un consortium sous les
dépenses annexes
alors arrive à s'en sortir en faire leur
tavail 3d vraiment fidèle des ronds et
moi même illusion le plaisir on décore
et u10 là je te demande de me dire de me
dire qui tu vois mon devoir
pourquoi si en même temps je vois
l'acteur de harry potter je vois harry
potter harry potter et à fait
intéressant c'est que eux n'ont pas vu
ça par contre ce que tu veux savoir ce
qu'ils ont vu tu veux dire que là je
veux briser toute mon enfance est choix
du tout avec pater ok mais si vous
l'aviez qu'est ce qu'il fout là à stein
c'est ouf ou pas témoin de leurs maîtres
donc ouais je t'ai même deuxième
personne parce que maintenant je l'aï en
tête je vais essayer de le voir du tout
ok le harry potter je le vois toujours
c'est dingue c'est quoi ces histoires de
les ombres et aquila est ce que ce
serait pas marine landrot issa et de
prix tu va m'apporter le visage d'une
enfance jeunesse nachi taille partout
mon pote à moi par contre je vois encore
s'ils vont réussir à avoir faim de
manière complètement alors en vidéo de
tête juste avant que je reprenne cette
phrase je vous les ai sûrement remis à
des distances différentes
je vous mets le fichier dans la
description si vous voulez l'imprimé
chez vous et le faire ça c'est vraiment
la première qui me surprend beaucoup et
j'invite à faire sur papier ouais
pouvoir imprimer le prix pour l'instant
et une fois que ces imprimés vous le
leaké sur le fait que les dirigeants
parents si vous présentez votre préféré
tu connais ça ou pas cher à rhodes et
bien un téléphone portable des cachets
dans cette photo alors oui j'ai dû la
voir là pour passer sur facebook
eh bien il faut le trouver à l'époque je
crois qu'il était dans island au joli
jeu vous souvenez qu'il jouera six mois
celle là je la connaissais oui eh bien
je vous le ferez voir que la fin de la
vidéo si vous ne l'aviez pas vu comme ça
vous pouvez chercher tu censurera
l'endroit où j'ai mis mon dos du coup on
pas que c'est inventé l'art de nine zone
est en fait prendre et 20 33 vices
cachés de notre côté en fait et c'est
lui le musée à l'étoile a troublé et
d'ailleurs tu fais gagner ce téléphone
rose s'étaient mis d'accord sur sa non
le tapis à l'hôte a fixé la veille aux
tapis d'accord j'ai un partenariat avec
tapis toile comme des petits pains qu'un
patient si vous savez que jusqu'à 10 les
dangers la faute juste que tu lis mes
textes en date est dans ma tête ce
paraguay ou avoir d'importants regard de
ce texte il va bouger
de droite à gauche et [ __ ] quand je
suis arrivé en bas effectivement il va
bloquer ou j'ai quand je vais en haut
mais plutôt en fait si le fait de passer
le directement d'autant bas toutes les
ombres elles sont calibrés pour que à la
lecture
cette phase les sanglots roga essais
commencent à bouger à ce moment là et ça
s'est fait avec trois fois rien mais
avec des ombres ya juste la bonne ombres
blanches et labo nombreux noirs et après
elle s'inverse
tu vois un coup l'ombre blanche et
deloitte un coup à gauche droite c'est
pareil pour le noir c'est hyper simple à
faire si jamais voulu faire ce genre de
truc chez eux ou avec vos photos vos
textes vos logos peu importe suffit
d'alterner comme ça ces ombres blanches
et noires
alors celui ci je sais qu'il a vu sur
mon twitter oui mais comme j'ai pas non
plus
toute la communauté qui me suit sur
twitter racheter moi sur twitter on se
suivra ce sera chouette je vous présente
celle ci ça m'empêchera pas qu'elle
marchera encore donc là la plupart
d'entre vous voient les rectangles ici
tous et tous ces carrés il ya tous ces
arrêts et en réalité il ya 16 cercle et
non pas et n'ont pas tous ces cas c'est
sa voie l'amour d'arriver à alterner la
bâloise manger à l'erreur mais on a tous
les cas récents comme ça je suis en
train d'accoucher
et si on se concentre bien en fait il y
adhérons la ba oui là là et il y en a -
4 96 en tout et c'est vrai que là il
voit bien les carrés en fait il a pris
quant à vue une fois les cercles c'est
fini après c'est bon bah ouais mais
d'autres peuvent voir les autres
continents avant un carré parfait alors
celle ci ça va te demander un peu de
concentration très bien fait là on
atteint des trucs que c'est certain que
tu connais pas tu va regarder ce point
si c'est des prix d'amérique
je connais un bio car même s'il
reconnaît pas aux loisirs et bien sûr
clinton et bush et je vais te demander
de fixer ce point rouge fabriquée en
quelques clics c'est quand même trente
secondes 40 secondes sur papier c'est un
petit peu plus long un moment donné je
retournerai en fait la feuille on aura
une photo encadrée dans le même format
avec un point rouge au même endroit je
garderai mon regard du règlement encore
tu garderas ce focus et que je ne sois
pas le seul fait retour on joue le jeu
du pois rouges si vous voulez donc là en
thermale qui devrait tout petit dans un
carré vous vous avez l'image en grand
pour le faire en même temps vous
regardez bien uniquement le point rouge
et prenez le temps c'est un petit peu
long mais je peux vous donner une
recette de quiche lorraine d'ici là
surfeurs de choses et de bien alors le
on va faire travailler la persistance
rétinienne c'est en connaît tous
mais il ya quelque chose d'autre qui va
rentrer en jeu est assez intéressant et
maintenant tu vas retourner l'image est
toujours focalisé sur le prend un rouge
toujours de quel côté clinton butin
visites sont bientôt ils sont inversés
mais si j'ai une robe lâché le point
rouge paraître un peu maintenant
c'est le même village exactement c'est
le même visage c'est ouf ou pas ils ont
mélangé les deux voilà le visage freitas
est un mélange des deux visages et quand
tu retournes si tu fais le même focus tu
vas voir tu m'etonnes à droite et tu va
reconnaître bush
à gauche le discours intéressant qu'à
ton cerveau dit non c'est pas le visage
que j'ai vu tout à l'heure la gauche ça
c'est ma persistance rétinienne qui fait
croire ça par contre celui d'à côté ça
doit être ça voilà barrières et
indirectement ça fait l'inversé d'un
coup ils échangent lui présente phare
ode ouais je le connais tu te rends 5
par mois sympa abonnez-vous ils vont pas
souvent non plus alors là c'est pareil
ça va se passer en 2 faye
ok les deux feuilles qui sont calibrés
sur le même format
on les passera un moment donné oui
laisser tenir ça est ton rôle est votre
rôle aussi un pour essayer de faire en
même temps c'est de focaliser sur le
banc du f
ok ok donc je garde mon sens si mais
ouais comme si j'avais fait une croix
ici faites le aussi j'ai été obligé de
te laisser de tenir un peu plus
longtemps parce que j'ai fait des tests
et autant sur un écran accalmie hier ça
marchait bien autant sur le papier faut
faut qu'on prenne un petit peu de temps
donc
après quand je vous soutiendrai l'image
ou quand tu vas faire un job et enlever
cette image là puis tu focalisent
également en dessous d'un f qui elle
sera au même endroit on attend
maintenant placement au même emplacement
es-tu bougera pas ton regard tu me diras
ce que tu vois tu peux rien parce que tu
es en train de manipuler loin de moi je
sais pas ce qu'il va se passer en fait
c'est pas faux qu'est ce que tu vas
faire alors je vais switch et maintenant
je pense que l'on est bon d'avoir mort
et blanc c'est simple à à tanger les
jeux hyper clara attend qu est il en
train de se passer
est-ce que tu fixes toujours le même non
droit oui tu veux de la couleur pas
payer que quand tu me l'a enlevé j'ai vu
du noir et blanc la joie le bloc est en
train de revenir la têt le bleu qui
revient télé colère qui reviennent beige
et le blanc noir g2
de ma part oui et donc si tu bouges les
yeux effectivement tu peux constater que
c'est complètement noir et blanc il n'y
a pas à g de couler il est possédé et
barrez vous mais non bien parce que dans
aia ce serait pas parce que je la
connaissais de base l'image on a non pas
du tout non jean coutu sa percée avec
autre chose mais ça me faisait rire de
préparer si on dit farhan alors ce qui
s'est passé pendant un millième de
seconde j'ai bu en noir blanc et je me
suis dit ah d'accord ok c'est sale et il
est en train de me faire il m'a sorti
les images en couleur et je la vois en
noir et blanc ok c'est bien fait et
après je voyais les couleurs qui est en
train de revenir et tu me dis est ce que
tu vois les couleurs au maire je les
voyais donc je vis à vis n'a pas duré si
longtemps que ça et après mais j'étais
toujours fixé étuvage été regardée et
long run en [ __ ] ok je sais juste
génial et là vous allez voir vous allez
voir des aliens alors que c'est du tom
cruise brad pitt du george clooney là où
les visages allongée ou là la gauche
n'était pas beau ça expose des trucs
rien et alors que les jets reconnu hop
et 1,8 g reconnu un clown à droite me
laver laver les yeux tout en glisse et
on dirait qu on ya rajouté le sait le
filtre comme ça pour faire des
distorsions c'est pas du tout une
question de vitesse ou quoi c'est
vraiment une question d'avoir mis les
yeux sur la même ligne au même endroit
ça suffit à donner cette illusion la
hoya et bien voici que j'avais à vous
montrer que la parole je me suis régalé
j'ai fait tout ce que je pouvais pour
essayer de vous surprendre a rejeté
obligé de passer par des classiques
quand même bon savon refusa il a dit non
on est maintenant je ne veux pas je
rappelle que tous les fichiers je
voulais mais en téléchargement les liens
des vidéos aussi tout ça vous avez
saladin dans la description était montée
de montpellier exprès je tiens à te
remercie c'est un grand exercice
et pour ceux d'ailleurs vraiment pour
prouver ma sincérité je mets ton numéro
de téléphone la description et vous
pouvez lui envoyer un message de
remerciement que tu devineras bien
évident mais maintenant le donner de
l'énergie tout à fait moi du coup j'ai
hâte maintenant d'aller voir les
commentaires dans la vidéo en dessous
pour voir quelle était la grèce est
vraiment lyon qui leur a le plus plu ma
préférence pour cela et je pense que si
ça a marché chez certains ça ça fait
leur affaire mais voilà voir qui c'est
qui ça marche et le téléphone un ermite
et fabian pas alors vous fera rouler le
téléphone si on a bien regardé je te
laisse le dire mais vas-y
en fait ça il est juste là en fait les
îles se suis dans la continuité de la
bande noire du motif du tapis et un
téléphone avec une coque à fleurs
blanches pourtant les fleurs sur le
tapis sont plus ou moins blanc mais un
peu plus foncée et là c'est du vrai
blanc
mais non il n'ya pas télé veille à
passer les balles mots je les ai pas dit
je veux mais vraiment mal et j'ai le
doute c'est comment sa tête est-ce que
c'est pas une conspiration contre -
est-ce qu'on ne sait pas un méga prend
ces photos débile de gens qui veulent
juste des commentaires sont heureux de
commencer qui dit ça y est c'est bon je
les c'est à dire que juste qu'ils ont
compris et tout est maintenant temps
c'est bien fait il y aura toujours
quelqu'un commentaires qui touchera un
screen merci encore à vous d'avoir
regardé cette vidéo n'hésitez pas à
liker à nous dire quel était votre
église y ont préféré n'hésitez pas aussi
à des tchèques et la chaîne de
pharmacies s'est pas encore pu ainsi ça
ça m'étonnerait mais si c'est le cas
quelle bonheur tu peux enfin découvrir
une nouvelle chaîne qui martèle très
bientôt sur youtube pour de prochaines
vidéos
allez ciao ciao je crois que la
meilleure illusion d'optique c'est là
parce que vous voyez en quoi ce alors là
je vous suis pas d'accord moi parle en
mode 2d bon alors on peut avoir les
visions de voir deux ronds mais si on
voit deux rondes a tout intérêt à
cliquer sur les deux roues d'accord mais
moi je suis partie pour ça regarde je
clique et savoirs dont qui a foulé les
planches d'euros et à vulcan appliquer
ce que ça fait incroyable clic mon pote
[Musique]